Depuis que j’ai eu la chance d’approcher
la tombe de la dame de Vix, son gigantesque
vase de bronze et son fabuleux torque d’or
pour un documentaire avec National Geographic,
j’avais envie de faire une vidéo sur les
femmes celtes de l’âge du Fer.
Car cette fabuleuse sépulture féminine n'est
pas un cas isolé.
A cette époque protohistorique, dans une
grande région au nord des Alpes, on voit
apparaître des tombes de femmes extraordinaires.
Enterrées avec des richesses considérables,
parfois avec des armes et des chars, des attributs
qu’on imagine plutôt masculins en temps
normal, celles qu’on nomme souvent les “princesses
celtes”, ont intrigué des générations
d’archéologues.
Elles posent en fait la question du genre
en archéologie.
C’est un thème qu’on a déjà évoqué
dans plusieurs vidéos de la chaîne : celle
sur l’anthropologue Margaret Mead dans les
années 1930, celle sur le prétendu matriarcat
primitif, celle sur la place des femmes en
Grèce antique, celle qui présente l’œuvre
de Michelle Perrot et on a aussi parlé dans
la dernière vidéo qui parle de Françoise
Héritier.
Ah ouais, on en parle souvent en fait…
Mais c’est normal, c’est l’une des grandes
questions transversales qui irrigue les sciences
humaines depuis les années 1970 et qui est
sans doute l’une des plus fécondes pour
repenser les sociétés du passé.
D’ailleurs quand l’archéologie s’en
empare, vous allez voir, ça ouvre des perspectives
inattendues.
Il faut dire aussi qu’il y avait de quoi
faire….
Il suffit de voir comment on a représenté
les humains de la Préhistoire jusqu’à
y’a pas si longtemps.
Qui chassait ? Les hommes.
Qui fabriquait les outils ? Les hommes.
Qui peignait au fond des cavernes ? Les hommes.
Y’avait comme un problème.
L’exemple qu’on va développer aujourd’hui,
celui des princesses celtes, nous permet d’entrevoir
une autre réalité et de questionner la manière
dont on perçoit le sexe ou le genre des individus
avec des vestiges archéologiques.
Avant de commencer, il faut préciser que
lorsqu’on va parler des Celtes ici, on ne
parle pas de l’Irlande ou de la Bretagne
du Moyen-âge.
Il est vrai que ce terme recouvre une chronologie
et une géographie très étendues, mais nous,
on va oublier les triskels, l’hydromel et
les clips de Nolwenn, et on va se concentrer
sur une période ancienne, celle du début
de l’âge du Fer.
En fait, cette période est la première où
l’on peut affirmer avec certitude le caractère
celte d’une population grâce aux textes
grecs et latins qui mentionnent leurs contacts
avec ces régions de l’intérieur du continent.
Bien sûr, les Celtes ne sont pas apparus
d’un seul coup à ce moment-là et il existe
une continuité avec les périodes plus anciennes
de l’âge du Bronze, mais en l’absence
de traces écrites, la langue et l’appartenance
ethnique sont impossibles à définir.
Cette époque des princesses celtes, c’est
donc celle de l’âge du Fer, et de sa première
subdivision qu’on nomme la culture de Hallstatt,
du nom d’un site archéologique d'Autriche.
Cette culture se développe au nord des Alpes,
entre 800 et 450 avant J.-C. environ.
C’est l’époque du début de la métallurgie
du fer en Europe centrale, qui entraîne de
profondes mutations dans les sociétés.
Les premières villes fortifiées apparaissent
et les chefs sont enterrés dans de riches
tombes couvertes par des tumulus.
A partir du VIe siècle, entre 600 et 500
avant J.-C., on observe un déplacement des
centres de pouvoir vers l’ouest, vers la
vallée du Rhin, de la Seine et de la Saône.
C’est peut-être à mettre en relation avec
la fondation de Marseille par les Grecs vers
600 avant J.-C. et l’apparition de nouveaux
circuits commerciaux à destination de la
Méditerranée.
Car le monde celtique était en fait un intermédiaire
commercial privilégié.
Profitant de sa position centrale en Europe,
il a fait le relais entre les îles britanniques,
la Baltique et la Méditerranée.
Les Grecs et les Etrusques cherchant à se
fournir en ambre ou en étain entretenaient
donc des échanges fréquents avec l’aristocratie
celtique qui s’enrichissait grâce au commerce.
Lingots d’étain contre amphores de vin,
perles d’ambre contre céramique peinte,
les marchands parcouraient le continent dans
tous les sens, 2500 ans avant Schengen ou
le Marché commun.
C’est dans ce contexte qu’apparaissent,
pour la première fois, des sépultures de
femmes totalement hors du commun.
Mais avant d’en faire une description, il
reste une question à poser : c’est quoi
une sépulture de femme ?
La réponse semble assez évidente, une tombe
de femme, c’est une tombe avec une femme
dedans.
Jusque-là pas de problème.
Sauf qu’en archéologie, les choses ne sont
pas toujours aussi simples.
Pour déterminer le sexe d’un squelette,
on s’attarde normalement sur des détails
anatomiques qui montrent un dimorphisme sexuel,
c’est-à-dire une différence de forme selon
le sexe des individus.
Le plus simple pour les spécialistes, si
on veut éviter de faire de coûteux tests
sur l’ADN fossile, c’est d’observer
les os du bassin qui sont clairement différenciés
entre les hommes et les femmes.
Mais parfois, on ne les a pas.
Parfois, l’acidité du sol a rongé les
ossements et tout le squelette a carrément
disparu.
Parfois, les techniques de fouilles anciennes
se sont concentrées sur les objets et ont
négligé d’étudier les restes osseux,
qu’on a depuis perdu.
En bref, on ne sait pas toujours si le défunt
était un homme ou une femme.
C’est là qu’on peut s’intéresser au
matériel funéraire.
Depuis des millénaires, les humains ont en
effet déposé des objets aux côtés de leurs
morts, surtout ceux qui appartenaient à l’élite.
Et ce matériel funéraire est souvent genré.
On ne dépose pas la même chose auprès d’un
homme ou d’une femme.
Le principe est assez intuitif et les archéologues
ont depuis longtemps pensé que les tombes
dans lesquelles on retrouvait des épées
étaient celles d’hommes tandis que celles
dans lesquelles il y avait des bijoux étaient
des tombes de femmes.
Et dans l’immense majorité des cas, c’est
vrai.
Mais bien sûr il y a des contre-exemples
qui brouillent les pistes.
Celle qui a été le plus loin pour démêler
tout ça et analyser le genre dans les sépultures
est Caroline Trémeaud, qui a justement fait
sa thèse sur la période qui nous intéresse
aujourd’hui.
On y vient.
En analysant plus de 721 tombes ostentatoires,
c’est-à-dire avec du matériel riche, réparties
entre la France, l’Allemagne, la Suisse,
l’Autriche et la République Tchèque, elle
est parvenue à déterminer des critères
pour genrer les objets déposés dans les
sépultures.
Un tel corpus, qui est le fruit du travail
de centaines d’archéologues depuis plus
d’un siècle, permet de mener des études
statistiques, et de dégager des tendances
générales et des évolutions bien marquées,
à l’échelle de toute une civilisation.
C’est donc un travail solide.
En résumé, pour la période qui nous intéresse,
les objets féminins sont plutôt les anneaux
de cheville, les paires de bracelets, les
couteaux, les perles, les bagues et les fusaïoles,
tandis que les objets masculins sont les arcs,
les poignards, les lances, les haches, les
épées, les casques, les pierres à aiguiser
et les outils en tout genre…
Entre ces deux pôles gravitent des objets
neutres, qui se retrouvent dans les tombes
féminines et masculines, tels que les torques,
les instruments de toilette, la vaisselle
métallique, les éléments de harnachement,
les chars, les brassards et les boucles d’oreille.
Ces objets-là ne renseignent pas sur le genre
de l’individu, cela ne veut pas dire que
l’individu n’était lui-même pas genré
de son vivant bien sûr, juste que le matériel
qu’on lui a attribué à sa mort ne le reflète
pas.
C’est comme si on déposait un smartphone
dans un cercueil, tout le monde en a un, ça
aide pas.
Sur ces 721 sépultures, seules 8 % des squelettes
avaient pu être déterminés anatomiquement
comme homme ou femme, mais grâce à cette
étude minutieuse du matériel qui les accompagnaient,
Trémeaud a pu déterminer le genre des défunts
à 96 %. Cela donne 24 % de tombes féminines,
52 % de tombes masculines, 20 % de sépultures
neutres ou mixtes, et 4 % d’indéterminées.
Le neutre ou mixte correspond ici au matériel
non-genré, vous avez compris.
Revenons à nos princesses.
Seulement 24 % de sépultures féminines,
ça fait pas beaucoup.
Mais il ne faut pas oublier qu’on parle
ici de tombes aristocratiques et que les fonctions
politiques et guerrières étaient monopolisées
par les hommes dans toutes les sociétés
anciennes.
Donc 24 % après tout, c’est peut-être
pas si mal…
Surtout qu’en y regardant de plus près,
les sépultures féminines sont les plus riches.
Grâce au calcul d’un indice de richesse
qui tient compte du nombre d’objets, du
poids de métal et de leur caractère exotique,
Caroline Trémeaud a pu montrer que les tombes
de femmes possédaient le matériel le plus
riche.
Je vous propose donc de passer en revue quelques-unes
de ces sépultures avant d’essayer de comprendre
quel a pu être le rôle de ces femmes extraordinaires
dans la société celte.
La plus célèbre est bien entendu la tombe
de Vix, dont j’ai parlé en introduction.
Découverte en 1953, au pied du mont Lassois
et au bord de la Seine, la tombe, datée d’environ
500 avant J.-C., était à l’origine recouverte
par un grand tumulus, arasé dans l’Antiquité.
A l’intérieur de la chambre funéraire
de trois mètres de côté, une femme reposait
sur un char avec des offrandes exceptionnelles
et parée de bijoux merveilleux.
Et puis quand je dis offrandes exceptionnelles,
c’est pas exagéré puisque dans cette sépulture
a été retrouvé le plus grand vase en bronze
de toute l’Antiquité.
Fait d’une seule tôle de bronze d’un
millimètre d’épaisseur, il pèse 208 kilos,
mesure 1m64 et peut contenir presque 1200
litres de liquide.
Sa forme et son décor de style grec illustrent
bien les contacts entre l’aristocratie celte
et le monde méditerranéen.
Sur le col se déroule une frise de soldats,
les anses portent des effigies de gorgones
entourées de lions et de serpents.
Le couvercle est orné d’une statuette féminine.
Les perles d’ambre et les inclusions de
corail dans les bijoux montrent aussi ces
contacts commerciaux à longue distance, vers
la Baltique et la Méditerranée.
Enfin, le torque, avec ses 480 grammes d’or
massif, est aussi un chef d'œuvre d’orfèvrerie.
Ses extrémités se terminent par des boutons
ornés de motifs géométriques et de pégases
ailés.
C’est une merveille.
Même si le fouilleur de la tombe René Joffroy
a tout de suite reconnu des parures féminines
dans la tombe, d’autres archéologues ont
eu du mal à accepter qu’il s’agisse d’une
sépulture féminine.
Le char, l’absence d’un époux inhumé
avec elle, la richesse du dépôt, tout suggère
la plus haute noblesse, peut-être même une
forme de pouvoir, et difficile d’imaginer
qu’une femme ait pu atteindre un tel statut
social.
Certains ont même émis l’idée d’un
prêtre déguisé en femme, mais bon depuis,
les os ont parlé, c’est bien une femme.
Fouillée en 1954 soit l’année après Vix,
la tombe princière de Reinheim (Raïnaïm)
est située à la frontière franco-allemande,
tout près de Sarreguemines.
C’est une tombe plus récente, datée d’environ
370 avant J.-C., qui illustre l’une des
dernières phases de ces riches sépultures
féminines.
Dans une grande chambre funéraire faite de
planches de chêne, une femme reposait avec
un très riche mobilier, dont un torque en
or torsadé, des bracelets et boucles en or,
un miroir en bronze et de la vaisselle métallique
de grande qualité.
L’acidité du sol a fait totalement disparaître
les ossements, mais le mobilier permet clairement
d’identifier une tombe féminine.
Tout indique encore une fois un statut extrêmement
élevé.
Les perles en verre et en ambre, matières
exotiques et très précieuses permettent
de reconstituer une grande parure.
L'élément le plus remarquable est sans doute
la cruche en bronze ouvragée, surmontée
d’un cheval à tête humaine.
Avec ses 50 cm de hauteur, c‘est la plus
grande connue dans le monde celte.
Des analyses chimiques ont montré qu’elle
était remplie de vin quand elle a été déposée
dans la tombe.
Aux côtés de la défunte était aussi présent
un bâtonnet sculpté en ambre avec des chaînettes
en argent.
Les fouilleurs l’interprètent comme un
élément cultuel, faisant peut-être de sa
propriétaire une femme impliquée dans le
culte, prétrêsse ou prophétesse.
Cette hypothèse est renforcée par la trouvaille
de nombreux petits objets interprétés comme
des amulettes, des curiosités telles qu’une
pointe de flèche néolithique en silex, des
billes de jaspe, un petit bloc d’hématite
ou un fossile d’ammonite.
A Bettelbühl (Bétèlbul), dans le sud de
l’Allemagne, une grande tombe féminine
a été fouillée bien plus récemment, entre
2010 et 2011.
La tombe a été trouvée à proximité de
la Heuneburg (Eunebourgue), qui est l’une
des plus importantes agglomérations celtes
de l’âge du Fer, et qui a livré de très
nombreux tertres funéraires.
Les liens avec le monde méditerranéen apparaissent
clairement par les vestiges d’un rempart
de terre crue, un matériau inhabituel dans
ces latitudes.
On suppose donc que des artisans grecs spécialisés
auraient pu participer à la construction
de la ville.
La particularité de la fouille qui nous intéresse,
c’est que les archéologues ont fait le
choix de prélever toute la sépulture de
la femme “en bloc”.
Un énorme bloc de 42 mètres cubes pesant
près de 80 tonnes a été transporté en
laboratoire pour être fouillé dans des conditions
optimales.
La présence d’une nappe d’eau persistante
a par ailleurs conservé de nombreux restes
organiques, en particulier la structure en
bois de la sépulture.
Grâce à la dendrochronologie, l’analyse
des cernes de croissance des arbres, les archéologues
ont pu dater le site avec un précision extrême
: l’inhumation date de 583 avant J.-C.
C’est une information capitale et il est
très rare de pouvoir poser des jalons aussi
précis dans la chronologie de l’âge du
Fer.
La tombe contient deux individus.
L’inhumation principale, au centre de la
chambre funéraire, est une femme âgée entre
trente et quarante ans.
Deux fibules d’or ont été déposées près
de ses épaules, et quatre fibules de bronze
décorées d’ambre sur sa poitrine.
Il y avait aussi des perles d’or et d’ambre
qui formaient un collier, de nombreux anneaux
et bracelets, dont sept en jais, ainsi qu’une
boucle en dents de sanglier avec des pendants
en bronze et des objets en bois.
Il n’y a pas de torque en or, comme à Vix
ou Reinheim, on n’en connaît pas dans les
tombes féminines si tôt au VIe siècle.
A côté de la défunte, une tombe d’enfant,
probablement une fille, a aussi fourni des
fibules et des pendants en or.
Pas très loin de ce site, le tumulus de Hohmichele,
un tertre de 80 mètres de diamètre et de
13 mètres de haut, soit le plus grand tumulus
de l’âge du Fer, a aussi livré des informations
importantes pour nous.
Fouillé il y a bien plus longtemps, il a
révélé plusieurs sépultures de couples
mixtes datant du VIe siècle avant J.-C.
Dans l’une d’entre elles, qui n’avait
pas été pillée, l’homme reposait sur
le sol, était vêtu assez modestement et
possèdait quelques armes, mais la femme en
revanche était déposée sur un char et très
richement dotée en perles d’ambre, de verre,
ou de corail, des matières très précieuses
et exotiques.
Une inégalité assez frappante.
Dans le tumulus du Grand-Communal, dans le
Doubs la tombe principale était celle d’une
femme portant des anneaux de jambe et des
pendentifs en bronze.
Deux autres femmes aussi dotées de parures
ont par la suite été inhumées auprès d’elle,
ce qui pourrait indiquer une succession générationnelle,
une sorte de lignée de grandes femmes.
Pas très loin, en Haute-Saône, dans le tertre
de Courtesoult-et-Gatey, six sépultures datées
du début du VIe siècle sont destinées à
des femmes et à une petite fille.
Les sépultures masculines n’apparaissent
que plus tard sur le site et sont bien moins
richement dotées.
Voilà pour ce rapide aperçu, il y a beaucoup
d’autres sépultures féminines ostentatoires,
et on pourrait continuer un moment à les
égrener.
Mais je pense que vous avez compris l’idée
: il se passe quelque chose avec les sépultures
féminines à cette époque.
Il y a plusieurs hypothèses pour expliquer
cette prééminence des femmes celtes au début
de l’âge du Fer.
Certains archéologues ont supposé que par
manque d’hommes dans l’élite à cette
époque, certaines femmes auraient exercé
des rôles masculins, devenant en quelque
sorte des « mâles honorifiques ». Reste
à savoir pourquoi tout à coup les mecs auraient
foutu le camp…
Bon.
Il y a aussi l’hypothèse de femmes avec
un rôle religieux important comme certains
objets peuvent le faire penser, mais les indices
sont souvent assez maigres, un miroir qui
aurait pu servir à la divination, quelques
amulettes…
D’autres ont imaginé que les femmes auraient
simplement été des vecteurs d’alliances
entre les hommes, des genres de femmes-trophées
qui marquaient le statut social des aristocrates.
Mais la richesse des tombes féminines, supérieure
à celle des hommes, rend difficile de les
imaginer comme des éléments passifs dans
ces échanges.
Une idée peut-être plus plausible est celle,
avancée par Pierre-Yves Milcent notamment,
d’une société matrilinéaire à cette
époque.
Une société matrilinéaire, c’est une
société dans laquelle les liens de filiation
se transmettent par la mère, et non par le
père.
C’est quelque chose d’assez courant dans
le monde.
Selon cette logique, les défuntes honorées
seraient ainsi des cheffes de lignages, des
ancêtres prestigieuses, auxquelles se rattachait
la communauté.
Cela expliquerait pourquoi de nouvelles tombes
étaient creusées à la périphérie de leurs
tumulus dans les décennies suivantes.
Les personnes inhumées près de ces grandes
femmes étaient peut-être les membres de
leur famille élargie.
Pour étayer son hypothèse, Milcent cite
un passage de Tite-Live, qui dans le livre
V de son Histoire romaine, décrit une invasion
gauloise menée par les neveux du roi des
Bituriges.
Ces neveux étant les fils de sa sœur, cela
accréditerait l’idée de matrilinéarité,
car l’oncle maternel fait alors souvent
office de père symbolique.
Une analyse ADN récente sur des sépultures
masculines semble aller dans le même sens.
L’ADN mitochondrial, transmis uniquement
par la mère, a démontré que les riches
défunts de la tombe de Hochdorf en Allemagne
et d’un grand tumulus voisin à Grafenbühl
étaient étroitement apparentés en ligne
féminine.
Mais même avec cette idée de femmes cheffes
de lignage, en fait, les archéologues se
retrouvent face à un vrai problème.
D’habitude, un riche dépôt funéraire
pour un homme est toujours interprété comme
un signe de pouvoir dans la société.
Des objets en or, un char, des armes, et nous
avons affaire à la tombe d’un roi, d’un
patriarche, pas d'un simple ancêtre.
Alors pourquoi ne pas imaginer cela pour des
femmes ? Pourquoi ne seraient-elles pas aussi
des matriarches ?
Et bien car le matriarcat… ça n’existe
pas.
Certaines femmes peuvent accéder à des statuts
élevés dans certains cas, mais partout,
dans le temps comme dans l’espace, les femmes
ont une place inférieure à celle des hommes.
L’anthropologue Françoise Héritier a appelé
ça la “valence différentielle des sexes”,
on en a parlé dans la dernière vidéo, et
c’est un invariant anthropologique, au même
titre que l’interdit de l’inceste.
Attention, hein, personne ne dit que l’inégalité
c’est très bien comme ça.
Au contraire, bref, allez voir la vidéo précédente
si c’est pas déjà fait.
Mais donc, sachant que les femmes n’ont
jamais eu le pouvoir, pourquoi ce serait différent
pour les Celtes de l’âge du Fer ? Ce serait
la seule société à avoir rompu ce principe
universel ? Mais d’un autre côté, pourquoi
une sépulture féminine devrait être interprétée
différemment d’une sépulture masculine
? Pourquoi quand on trouve un homme avec de
riches objets, comme celui d’Hochdorf, ou
celui de Lavau, fouillé par l’INRAP en
2014, on affirme que ce devait être un chef,
et quand on trouve une femme avec des richesses
comparabes voire supérieures, on dit que
ce serait une simple femme-trophée ?
Il subsiste donc une contradiction, et finalement
un paquet d’incertitudes.
Et quand on ne comprend pas la logique, c’est
soit qu’on a pas assez de données archéologiques
pour réfléchir, mais bon, avec des centaines
de tombes et des statistiques dans tous les
sens, ça commence à être clair, soit…
qu’il y peut-être des biais cachés dans
nos raisonnements.
Il ne faut pas oublier qu’on ne peut pas
observer la société celte, mais seulement
les sépultures de sa classe dirigeante.
Le portrait est forcément déformé.
Est-ce que les tombes de femmes importantes
ailleurs sont invisibles parce qu’elles
n’ont pas droit à de telles offrandes ? Ou
bien, est-ce que les objets féminins celtes
nous paraissent riches et importants alors
qu’ils ne l’étaient pas tant ? Le problème
est-il notre perception du genre ou de la
richesse ?
En bref, et pour ne pas finir que sur des
questions sans réponse, Caroline Trémeaud
propose une dernière hypothèse pour expliquer
cette richesse féminine au début de l’âge
du Fer.
C’est celle, assez séduisante je dois dire,
d’un rôle actif des femmes comme entrepreneuses
dans des réseaux de commerce international.
En un mot, elles auraient été des “business
women” protohistoriques.
Tous ces produits exotiques comme l'ambre,
l'étain, le cuivre, les céramiques peintes
ou les vases ouvragés qui circulaient plus
que jamais à l’époque, auraient pu être
échangés sous leur direction, et elles en
auraient ainsi conservé la preuve jusque
dans la mort.
Voilà ce qu’on peut dire des fameuses “princesses
celtes”.
Pas de réponse définitive, mais il y aurait
encore plein d’aspects à évoquer pour
cette période, comme les quelques cas de
transgression de genre, autrement dit des
hommes inhumés avec des objets clairement
féminins ou le contraire.
En élargissant, on pourrait aussi parler
des régions du monde où l’on connaît
des tombes de femmes guerrières comme la
Suède ou l’Arménie, mais on se réservera
peut-être ça pour une prochaine fois.
N’hésitez pas à regarder la bibliographie
en description si vous voulez en savoir plus,
plusieurs articles sont disponibles gratuitement
en ligne et vous aurez des éléments supplémentaires.
D’ailleurs, merci à Caroline Trémeaud
qui nous a gentiment envoyé l’un de ses
articles qu’on arrivait pas à trouver sur internet